one of the reasons we are Democrats is
that how people think and feel and react
actually matters as opposed to just our
blueprint view of the world well here we
are on the Sunday special with former
Canadian Prime Minister Stephen Harper
as a brand new book out we'll be talking
all about that but first let's talk
about your impending doom so life
insurance isn't the most enjoyable thing
to talk about because most people don't
like thinking about plotting but
actually having life insurance it's a
good feeling because it's nice to know
that if anything were to happen to you
your family won't have to start a
GoFundMe to stay afloat policy genius is
the easy way to get life insurance
online in just two minutes you can
compare quotes from the top insurers to
find the best policy for you and when
you compare those quotes you save money
it is indeed that simple policy genius
has helped over 4 million people shop
for insurance and they've placed about
20 billion dollars in coverage they
don't just do life insurance they also
do disability insurance and auto
insurance and home insurance if you care
about it they can cover it so if you've
been avoiding getting life insurance
because it's tough or confusing give
policy genius a try just go to policy
genius com get your quotes applying
minute so you do the whole thing on your
phone right now you should just pause
the show go to policy genius take care
of it policy genius is indeed the easy
way to compare and buy life insurance
again policy genius ensures that you get
the life insurance that you need if
you're too lazy to get it you're being a
bum don't do it
be a responsible human go get life
insurance policy genius calm the easy
way to compare and buy life insurance
well Prime Minister Harper thanks so
much for stopping by oh thanks for
having me I'm but looking forward to
this well the very first time that I met
you I I knew who you are you know who I
was but I was up in Canada to cover the
American election for Sun News back in
2012 and we met and I at the time Barack
Obama was president and so in the
interest of full disclosure I do have to
admit that I did ask you to invade the
United States at the time to which he
responded isn't that treason and then I
replied well it isn't if you win so the
good news is that you that was not
necessary didn't actually have to invade
the United States but with that said now
you're on this book tour you have a
brand-new book out right here right now
politics and leadership in the age of
disruption really is all about populism
I want to talk start by talking a little
bit about your personal political
journey so we're always conservative how
did you find yourself so long story when
I was
you know a kind of a bright eager
gold-medalist high school student I came
out of conventional public education
with left-liberal conventional left
liberal views
I had a big sea change when I was in my
early 20s I was working in the oil
industry and the government of then
Pierre Trudeau brought in something
called the national energy program in
which they tried to socialize and
re-engineer the entire industry they
went drove the unemployment rate from 3%
to 13% in six months not to mention what
they did to taxes in the deficit and
ultimately a national recession and so
that really transformed my political
thinking and then I worked in politics
and kind of went from there went from
being a kind of went to the right became
a then conventional more Center as
conservative became more as I watched
the in 1984 we elected a Conservative
government that I went worked for turned
out not to be very conservative and kind
of but kind of had the effect of making
me more philosophically conservative
long story after that I left the
government I ended up getting involved
in the founding of a populist
conservative party the Reform Party of
Canada that eventually morphed into
through various mergers morphed into the
new Conservative Party of Canada that I
founded and so that's kind of my my
background so I've been a I've been a
conservative since I was in my early 20s
and I've been kind of had a populist
conservative bent since my late 20s when
I kind of got exposure to that stream of
conservatism and I'm also an economist
by training so that obviously helped to
further my conservative viewpoint so who
are your sort of chief ideological
influences like books that you'd read or
folks that you watch and you thought
okay well that that person has exposed
expositing sort of conservatism that I
find attractive yeah I don't know that I
can point to anyone I always liked the
classical economist you know from Adam
Smith forward I tended to like you know
Freedman people people kind of had a
what I would call practical applied
conservatism I was I was I was always a
bit distrustful of the extreme kind of
abstraction of modern rational
expectations or these sorts of schools
but and of course in terms of the
political arena I mean I
my my hero of all time would be Winston
Churchill but I was you know I think of
my own personal experiences through the
matter of the one individual probably
had the most influence on my own
political thinking was preston manning
who was the founder of the Reform Party
even though we don't always see eye to
eye he probably had more influence of
any living person on my philosophy than
anybody where do you draw the line
between what you call populist
conservatism and other forms of
conservatism because the book is largely
about that you know what is populism I'd
always maintained that populism is more
of a style than it is necessarily an
ideology just because you've got
populist folks on in the United States
populist folks like Bernie Sanders and
you have populist folks like Donald
Trump and it seems like the only common
thing between them is just saying that
they stand for the people yeah look I
agree with that I think populism is
actually a pretty thin ideology now it
has a history and a particular meaning I
think is interesting but leaving that
aside in its modern manifestations it is
offended ideology and it tends to be
often more about style but you know I
would argue that real conservatism is
actually populist conservatism it's non
theoretical and it is targeted towards
kind of the interests of ordinary people
and their concerns and that's what I
would argue populist conservatism is so
there are a lot of folks on the right
who they hear something like you know
non-ideological and more pragmatic and
what they hear is government right cuz
typically when folks say I'm a pragmatic
conservative it sounds like John Kasich
in Ohio what I really want is to expand
Medicare what I really want is to ensure
that everybody is taken care of by the
government where do you think those
things are that's that's a great
question because often you'll see the
same thing happen in Canada I'm a
pragmatist or I'm a satirist and of
course coming from a mouth of a
conservative it often means actually
they're left to Center but somehow want
to be in a conservative party i I mean
I'm talking firmly about conservative
values belief in markets belief and you
know traditions family faith the flag
etc but applied to real world problems I
the problem I had when I talk about you
know theoretical abstract conservatives
is the kind of conservatism that you
know has an agenda that was written by
Ronald Reagan in the 1980s and we should
follow this kind of regardless of
circumstances I'm talking about applying
real conservative ideas to contemporary
problems that actually need to be fixed
in the interests of ordinary people
that's different than just watering
your principles it's applying your
principles to real-world situations do
you see any distinction between sort of
Canadian conservatism and American
conservatism or is it basically you know
two branches of the same tree no I think
they're distinct I think actually what
makes conservatism distinct as opposed
to philosophies on the left it's because
conservatism is empirical and
fundamentally cultural conservatism
actually does differ to some degree in
various entities whereas liberalism and
socialism and the real isms are kind of
their kind of belief systems regardless
you've got to transform whatever society
it is into that so Canadian conservatism
is different it's it's I would I would
say several differences that are
discernible it's it is more
communitarian less individualistic not
to say it's not individualistic but sort
of on if you see conservatism as a
balance of liberty and order it's more
on the order side than on the Liberty
side it's also of course you know
conservatism in Canada historically and
presently means support for the
institution of the crown which of course
in the United States conservatism is
based on on on opposition to the crown
and and their kind of values that go
along with this these are these are
things at the margin it's not like a
Canadian conservative and American
conservative would not have very similar
views on most issues but unlike a
liberal or a socialist their views would
not be identical mhm and how do you
think that manifests in terms of
policies so for example I just spent
some time up in Vancouver it seems like
right left and center there's a lot of
support for the health system in Canada
of course you say health system in
Canada can two conservatives in the
United States we run screaming into a
tree where does conservatism in Canada
sort of stand on the status of the
nationalized healthcare system and in
the country well I look I I never really
had to tackle that in a meaningful way
and that the the hella we call a
national health system but in fact the
health systems are run by the provinces
not by the federal government and you
know there is kind of fun there is
fundamental there's fundamental
agreement around the core principle of
you know medical necessary medical care
should not be based on whether you can
or cannot pay for it that I think is a
principle that frankly people across the
spectrum would agree on there'd be
differences in agreement about how that
has to
you deliver to what degree does the
delivery have to be public versus
private or could there be options or
competition and the fact is you know we
go on stereotypes here I mean the fact
is that much of Canadian health care is
private there are a lot of uninsured
services there's lots of extra services
you get through an X and you know
pharmaceuticals etc that you can obtain
through private insurance in Canada
likewise in the United States every
senior citizen is under socialized
medicine so the difference is not as
radical as people sometimes think okay
so when it comes to a populist
conservatism you talk about some some
areas where this would be
distinguishable specifically from sort
of a libertarian perspective on a
variety of issues let's start with with
sort of the perspective on nationalism
so there's been a big debate in the wake
of President Trump about nationalism on
the right so there are some folks like
Jonah Goldberg I think I would count
myself in this camp who are who are very
attached to the idea of patriotism but
not nationalism there are a lot of folks
like rich Lowry at National Review again
one of our colleagues there who's very
attached to nationalism as distinct from
patriotism do you see a distinction
between nationalism and patriotism not
really so I argue in the book that a
healthy nationalism is part of a healthy
society you know I think the the kind of
the germany's of the world where
nationalism for historical reasons
become kind of inherently suspicious is
just it's frankly just wrong and wrong
for conservatives now in that sense as I
say I'm using patriotism and nationalism
as virtually interchangeable I would
agree that if you get kind of far-right
national ISM that's essentially ethnic
or racial and character it could become
a different kind of beast but frankly
conservatives don't advocate that kind
of nationalism
right okay so where do you stand on on
immigration so in the United States
obviously this would become a massive
question considering president from his
position on the border and there are a
variety of physicians we've got sort of
the libertarian position that says you
want to come in and more come on in and
work but you don't necessarily get
citizenship you've got the kind of far
left and now mainstream left position
come on in no matter what you will try
and give you citizenship you don't have
to assimilate you've got the hard right
restriction especially you're
undercutting our labor base don't come
in at all we don't want you here where
do you come down on that we think
conservatives elements of a couple of
those things first of all I you know the
Conservative Party of Canada
is one of the few right-of-center
parties the world that gets a large
percentage and sometimes an outright
majority of the immigrant vote so we're
very distinct that way in a way that's
very positive I'm I'm fundamentally Pro
immigration I think one of the things
that has made kin of the United States
and our society successful is that we
embrace newcomers who often you know I
frankly who are often conservatives
their entrepreneurial their ambitious
their aspirational they believe in
family they believe in faith they're
opposed to crime etc so I actually
actually think conserve properly done
immigrants should be a really great base
for a conservative party but first and
foremost immigration has to be legal
immigration is not a right immigration
is something granted by the citizens of
the country through law I have no time
for illegal immigration and as I've told
other leaders in other countries no
illegal immigration system or phenomenon
will ever be popular with the massive
people it just will not
obviously in modern day and age the
immigration system should be scoped
primarily around the country's economic
needs
there can be humanitarian family
considerations but it's it's
fundamentally about the economy and
about building our society so look I'm
fundamentally it is what I say about so
much in the book I'm fundamentally Pro
immigration just like I'm fundamentally
pro trade pull markets but that doesn't
mean that immigration is good no matter
what that having you know caravans of
people invading the country would be a
good thing or that you can live frankly
what I would consider the libertarian
delusion that people will come into the
country but somehow they will no access
to social services like just never going
to happen so you know it's got to be
it's got to be a policy rooted in what
we have seen to be successful over the
decades well one of the arguments that's
happened sort of inside the Republican
Party here has been an argument between
I would say sort of the Tom cotton wing
of the Republican Party on immigration
and maybe the Ted Cruz wing Ted Cruz is
very much in favor of for example what
we call h-1b visas people coming in for
high-tech jobs right and he says okay
well you know you wanna bring talent in
bring talent in those folks can work
here it makes our economy more
competitive Tom cotton says those are
jobs that are being taken away from
people who live in the United States we
should restrict immigration along those
lines where do you stand on that in
terms of economics well I think that's
an empirical question I think the truth
is that you know certain
if you look at the Canadian labor market
I would suspect the same thing is true
in the American labor market that you
have lots of jobs in occupation where
the economy has needs right away and
there simply aren't the kind of numbers
to fulfill them and bringing into the
country people are educated are gonna
fit in with a job right away and be
productive citizens that's a positive
thing obviously and this is this is a
big problem I have with American
immigration policy today fact is is that
American immigration policy through
family connections through illegal
immigration is often bringing in
low-skilled labor tons of low-skilled
labor at the very time in history where
we know there's there's fact never been
a time in history where low-skilled
labor is under more pressure downward
pressure on it's on it's on it's wages
and it's living standards and it's
opportunities because of the evolution
of economy why would you why would you
bring in that kind of labor as opposed
the kind of labor the economy needs so
as I said I think it's an empirical
question i i i would really doubt that
there's an argument to say the u.s. has
no need for immigrants and that there's
no immigrants who could possibly help
build the american economy i think
that's a nonsensical position but what's
happened in the united states and this
is what happens where you have unpopular
or illegal immigration public opinion
turns against all immigration and that's
what i say a good conservative approach
would seek to avoid well in a second i
want to ask you about the the trade
policy that you would like to see
pursued under sort of a populist
conservative rubric but first let's talk
about your investments Robin Hood is an
investing app that lets you buy and sell
stocks ETFs options cryptos all
commission-free they strive to make
Financial Services work for everyone not
just for rich folks none it's a non
intimidating way for stock market
newcomers to invest for the first time
with true confidence and it is simple
and intuitive there are folks at the
office who use it they say that it makes
things really clear other brokerage
brokerages charge up to 10 bucks for
every trade Robin Hood doesn't charge
commission fees you trade stocks and you
keep all your profits and again they
have all these easy-to-understand charts
they have all the market data they place
a trade in just four taps on your
smartphone robin hood's web platform
also lets you view stock collections
that are cultivated just for you things
like 100 most popular or social media or
curated categories like female CEOs if
this is the thing you care about analyst
ratings of every buy hold sell for every
stock learn how to invest as you build
that portfolio
over time you can discover new stocks
track favorite companies with
personalized news fees custom
notifications for price movements he
never missed the right moment to invest
again all of these tools are available
when you use Robin Hood and Robin Hood
right now is giving my listeners a free
stock like an Apple Ford or sprint to
help build your portfolio all you have
to do is sign up at Ben Shapiro Robin
Hood comm that's Ben Shapiro dot Robin
Hood calm again go check it out Ben
Shapiro dot Robin Hood calm all right so
let's go to trade because we actually
may have some some differences of
opinion on trade so president Trump has
been quite anti trade in his rhetoric in
policy less so because I think he's been
moderated by a lot of members of his own
administration you know a populist
conservatism either the question is
whether that's gonna be a pro trade
concerns ism you talk about how you're
Pro free trade there are certain areas
however where you're a lot more
restriction is done trade particularly
regard to China so where where do you
fall down on sort of the trade divide
first of all just my background the
government I led negotiated virtually
all of Canada's contemporary trade
agreements except for a NAFTA except for
them obviously the new u.s. MCA so I
think and in fact I probably have a
record of signing more trade deals in
just about any leader in the free world
alive today so I I don't have much
trouble saying that I'm Pro trade but
look President Trump came along I
remember when we had this debate in the
election he came along and he started
talking about good deals and bad deals
and people went oh you know some some
quote economist started saying oh wow
he's a protectionist bad deals he could
be a protectionist but can you have a
bad trade deal absolutely you can have a
bad trade deal I mean when when
companies let's forget about governments
when companies do a commercial deal with
another company why do they have dozens
of analysts and lawyers and accountants
working over these deals because any
deal would be a good deal I mean
seriously you have to really know what
you're talking about when you negotiate
something as complex as a trade deal in
the United States when the United States
allowed China to enter the WTO we set up
a situation Canada's in the same boat
where the Chinese have wide-ranging
unfettered access to almost all of our
economy and we can only sell to the
Chinese when where and in what quantity
and for how long they say we can
and obviously in that kind of situation
what have we seen we have Mia seen
massive imbalances imbalances by the way
yeah you know economists will say a poor
country like China's bound of a trade
surplus with the United States but it's
not bound to get bigger as China gets
more wealthy which is what is happening
this is because you have a bad deal that
provides grossly unequal access and the
consequence has been the outflow of
millions of jobs from the United States
from Canada to China with no discernible
benefits to our working population so as
a populist conservative or frankly I
would say as a conservatives you don't
sign deals like that you sign deals
where you know that overall your economy
is going to benefit and that lots of
people in your economy are going to
benefit the countervailing case that's
been made by particularly libertarians
on trade has been why would you tax your
own citizens by essentially terrifying
Chinese products in order to punish the
Chinese I mean is the goal to have them
lower their own tariffs or is the goal
to cut them out of the market because
they're quote-unquote sucking our jobs
out the fact is that we've gotten a lot
of cheap products out of China and
people tend to see that as a bad thing
but the fact is that consumer prices
have been going down in the United
States consistently yeah but that's it
but that's a terrible argument you know
it's a terrible argument first of all
the the question of whether the tariff
policy is effective is a different
question but the the argument made by
the apologists for the current Chinese
trade relationship is look yeah so we've
lost all these jobs so we've lost you
know all these factories and everything
that moved to China but we get cheap
products but you know what I get to sell
stuff to you and you get to buy it
that's not a trade relationship that's a
purchase and that's that's not the
justification for trade you know even
people these libertarians will jump up
and quote David Ricardo and classical
economist David Ricardo didn't say it
would be a good idea for Britain to open
its markets if it couldn't sell its
goods anywhere else
he made the argument for reciprocal
trade and that is the core of the
argument for reciprocal trade and the
idea that a trade relationship no matter
how badly structured is somehow good for
you losing jobs losing well-paying jobs
by the millions to get cheap products
which by the way in most cases you could
get from places other than China is not
an argument for
kind of trade imbalance we have seen and
the kind of economic overflows we've
seen that's by the way you know
obviously there's a separate question
about China being a geopolitical and
strategic rival but even leaving that
aside that's not a good economic
relationship and the president my view
the president not only is right the
president deserves the first lot of
credit is the first president willing to
take on this the current trade
relationship with China is beneficial to
a few well-connected American
corporations who get to operate in China
but it's not beneficial to the economy
as a whole and something has to be done
about that or we are going to see a
situation where the Chinese is the
largest China's economy is the largest
in the world with a grossly unequal
trade access the United States and
that's not in anybody's interest I mean
the fact is again if they have a grossly
unequal trade access to the United
States we still are you know getting
cheap products much cheaper than they
were thirty years ago with a three with
the three to four hundred when now close
to four hundred billion dollar outflow
right well again their capital account
surpluses I mean that money has to go
somewhere and presumably it's going into
buying all of the debt that we're
selling them so you know I just think
it's a nonsensical argument it's it's
contrary to common say that contrary to
common law I mean our deficits always
bad no trade deficits are not always bad
and trade deficits under many
circumstances would be expected we know
as you know I know as an economist it's
likely the poorer country will have a
trade surplus with a richer country
simply because a richer country can buy
more goods it's also you know I would
argue the case of Canada Canada in the
last few years has tended to have a
small trade surplus with the United
States why because of the energy trade a
vital commodity that the United States
as a special has had a special need for
but is I trade it's a trade deficit in
and of itself nothing to worry about
look anybody who thinks that trade
surpluses don't matter as far forgotten
to tell the Chinese because they are
building their economy into a powerhouse
through a deliberate strategy of running
trade surpluses with Western so I guess
this is the real question do you think
they're building their economy into a
powerhouse are they building themselves
into a military geopolitical powerhouse
with that extra cash meaning it's it
seems to me the Darracq on their
economic plans are unsustainable
subsidizing certain industries and
cutting out other industries as a result
is not a sustainable path for any
country that wishes to be growing into
the future and
actually developing into the future but
it is a good path for centralizing
capital right now and then using that
capital in order to expand your your
military dominance in the region so look
I would say there's aspects of Chinese
economic policy are not sustainable over
the long term in the building empty
cities but well not entirely I've been
to all those cities they're pretty fault
the fact of the matter is these you know
they've created tens of millions of jobs
and some of those tens of millions of
jobs have been created through not
through direct subsidy and some of its
direct subsidies some of its
international to some of its
intellectual property theft but some of
it is just by having access to a market
and restricting access to their own
market keeping cash in the in China and
bringing more cash into China so the
idea that we should never worry about a
surplus no matter what the circumstances
I just think defies economic logic the
tariffs are that good why don't we using
them meaning that it is in China because
every country uses tariffs all the time
I mean to the extent of the Chinese are
so meaning that China is obviously
terrifying American products you say to
say yeah but it's more of them I think
the real problem in China is greater
than the tariffs the real problem in
China is that the Chinese government
basically sanctions entry into your
market with or without a tariff unless
the government says you can sell in the
market and you can continue to sell you
cannot sell period which which by the
way I think is where the Trump
administration is likely to head over
time if they can't get the Chinese
market more open I think they're
basically going to establish a managed
trade relationship with China where they
say okay if we can't enter into your
market some of your products you just
not going to enter into our market and
you're starting to see that in some of
the technology space so do you think
that the end goal should be to get the
Chinese to get rid of these tariffs on
our product the end where the young goal
should be for China have its market more
open not just tariffs down but have a
more open marketplace there's no reason
for instance that American and Canadian
consumer product agency shouldn't be
able to sell freely on Alibaba which
they can't today no reason that should
be prevented and by the way and we're
we're margon about this being economic
logic it's not that the Chinese don't
want these products right they'll pay a
premium for these products they want our
products so we should have an
opportunity there so yeah that obviously
I would never support don't you ever I
would never support the idea of the
administration pursuing any kind of
trade war in that with it protectionism
as the goal but the goal to be
reciprocal
market-opening is completely reasonable
I think the challenge been is that the
whole nature of the Chinese economic
structure and the nature of the
government's role in the economy raises
questions as to whether they can really
truly open their markets in the way
we're expecting or whether they're
always reserve the right to just shut
them at the drop of a hat and then this
does raise the question of security risk
so it seems to me that if you're gonna
direct trade policy it for the United
States or for any other Western country
with regard to China then as you say
there should be a couple of goals and
this has sort of been lirikhug lows
point inside the the trade relationship
that he's basically running trade for
for Trump Trump keeps saying he likes
protectionism and then Kudlow says no
what he really means is what he really
means that he wants to use our trade
policy in order to lower tariffs and
trade barriers in in other places which
seems correct and then that seems I
think in fairness I mean I've been like
you I've been critical of many things
about Donald Trump especially during his
run for the presidency I think if you
look on balance his record to date would
indicate that he is a guy using perfect
protectionist measures to open markets
rather than to pursue protectionism but
I think there's the jury's still out on
some aspect no I think that's right I
think that whether he intends to or not
that's what he is doing meaning that I
think that you know in his head from
everything that he says he sounds like a
guy who doesn't actually get basic
Riccardi and economics but but his trade
people do and so they're able to he is
all he is also a businessman that's for
sure
so he gets the the practical issues of
whether it matters that you can actually
sell products as opposed the theoretical
arguments about trade so it seems to me
that so possibility one use those those
measures in order to lower the trade
barriers in places like China and
possibility number two is that he
actually as many of his advisers who
sees China as a as a geopolitical threat
and he feels like helping them grow
their economy is actually a geopolitical
problem that the goal shouldn't be
necessarily open up the Chinese market
to American goods and creating a better
reciprocal trade relationship maybe the
goal should actually be to curb Chinese
power in the region and so when he says
national security is a rationale for
trade policy he actually means it he
actually means that well look here is I
discuss this issue in my book I think
the history with the United States it
really stems from post-world War two
in the mercial plan American policy
essentially has become we promote you
know since the Marshall Plan
we promote open trade and open markets
because first of all even if we give
unequal access where the United States
and the relationship where the bigger
guy it benefits us anyway and secondly
the effect of open trade and open
markets is to produce open and
democratic societies then end up being
American friends or allies now I think
that theory is really being tested with
China because here you have a country
that could conceptually be in fact
probably will be a bigger economy than
the United States but furthermore the
entire practice of its economic policy
is explicitly for the purpose of not
opening up the governing structures of
the country it is in fact to preserve
the constitutional the the the
authoritative monopoly of the Communist
Party and its method of governance and I
would argue to be a strategic rival of
the United States certainly if you
believe Xi Jinping that's exactly what
they intend so I think these things get
mixed up now would I say that it's I
would still be in the Henry Kissinger
school that if you can engage in a
genuine relationship that opens up China
in time that is bound to make China even
a much bigger China society more like
Western democracies and more friendly
and less confrontational with Western
democracies but that's a theory and that
theory isn't panning out real well at
the moment yeah well let's talk a little
bit I know we're jumping around a fair
bit in terms of yeah that's what you do
but yeah exactly
let's let's talk a little bit about the
situation in Europe because what we've
been told I mean since we're talking
about populism yeah we'd be remiss not
to talk about the rise of populist
movements in Europe
yeah I'm reason I wrote the book is not
just the United States virtually every
Western country except Canada has seen
the rise of a populist movement do you
think that all those populism czar
similar meaning that Donald Trump's
populism do you see that is similar to
the rise of populist movements in places
like Germany or France or Austria or the
Nordic countries or is it of a different
kind so none of these populism czar
identical some I would call you know I
think the Trump phenomenon certainly the
brexit move in the UK these would be
fundamentally kind of setter right
populist movements obvi
in Italy five star movement clearly on
the left there are left-wing populist
movements and there are populist
movements on in Europe that would be
anti market the kind of visceral I think
nationalism you're talking about that
would be of a totally different nature
March stream right type so so these
movements can be different but I would
say that a lot of them have
commonalities and and the commonalities
they've tended to have in this era is
raising questions about the functioning
of market economies questioning trade
and trade agreements questioning
globalization certainly and European
Union in Europe as a form of that and
questioning immigration now the way they
question the types of solutions they
advocate I think distinguishes them but
those are the common threads so what do
you make of the the argument that's made
by a lot of folks particularly on the
Left there's something specifically
threatening about the rise of these
populist movements that it's not just
reaction toward conservatism you know a
movement away from the left and toward
conservatism in reaction to open borders
leftism
or globalization based leftism but that
this is led to this dangerous rise in
xenophobia it's led to the rise
far-right I think I think it's a really
an overgeneralization first of all I I
guess I argue that fundamentally most of
these populist movements today they're
they're largely on the right and where I
think they should attract our attention
is in many cases they're garnering what
would have been considered mainstream
center right or even center left voters
and that's what should concern us
I tend to think as I and I think there's
be a surprising conclusion as a guy who
ran a governor that was pro market
pro-trade Pro Bowler ization Pro
immigration I said if you actually look
at the complaints of these populist
movements and you look at the facts the
facts are actually tend to bear out that
they have legitimate grievances I think
it is in the solutions that we can
sometimes get concerned and the reason I
wrote the book is I consider these
things today more wake-up calls than
dangers you may not like Trump you may
not like brexit but these are people
Donald Trump nigel Faraj these are
people fundamentally trying to fix what
they see ailing democratic capitalist
societies that is very different than
the Bernie Sanders or jeremy corbyn's
that want to destroy them
out of capitalist societies and that's
that's where I draw the line so where I
tend to look at these so-called populist
movements or nationalist movements in
Europe are they are they movements that
are responding to kind of genuine
concerns about how the European Union
functions or how ordinary people are
doing versus countries that are kind of
demanding a form of ethnic right-wing
socialism which i think is an entirely
different beast and that is I think that
the big question right now so I remember
during the 2016 election there are a lot
of arguments about this because
President Trump talked about populism he
wasn't super clear about what he meant
by that and so this created a serious
rift between sort of the conservative
side of the Republican Party in the
populist side I want to talk about that
and whether that is America specific or
whether you think that that is breaking
out in other places too first we have to
talk about that face of yours I mean
come on
the saggy draw line ladies and gentlemen
it's that draw line the double chin that
gives your age away well not anymore
introducing the brand-new genja cell
drawn line treatment with dual peptide
and MDL technology Japanese most
advanced technology ever it not only
tightens that saggy jawline it also
plumps the lipophilic layers of your
skin wow you didn't think I'd say that
word correctly but I did to contour and
define the jawline within minutes using
peptides and metal lactones together for
the first time it works amazingly
quickly and the results get better every
day no one else has this technology or
shamon ease proprietary chemical free
base so say goodbye to that double chin
right now I know she how many products
are good because my wife uses them and
when they arrive my mom steals them
here's the best news it is yours free
when you order Jen you sell for under
eye bags and puffiness and for results
in 12 hours Jen you sells immediate
effects it's also free text chin because
you have two of them
277 of 453 seven seven four or five
three or go to Jen you sell calm for
this amazing introductory offer imagine
that double chin disappearing in about a
week with genja cells drawn line
treatment I won't mention the folks in
popular entertainment who could use this
a hundred percent guaranteed or your
money back stop imagining call or click
now text chin into seven seven four five
three or go to Jenny Cellcom again text
that word chin two seven seven four five
three well back to a serious time so the
the gap that we've seen in the
Republican election base yeah this was a
fight that I had with a lot of people
who considered themselves populist is
that I looked at Europe and I said I
don't want the American Republican Party
turning into a European far-right
because it seems like there is actually
a distinction and you obviously being
from Canada maybe you can either tell me
whether this is correct or not an
American conservatism is of a slightly
different brand then then conservatism
in Europe or in other countries in that
based on the idea of god-given rights
protected by a limited government the
essential assumption is that if
something comes up it is not the
government's job and populism sort of
suggests there's a problem and now it is
the government's job and so if there is
a if there's a problem in your town and
you've lost you've lost jobs in that
town now it's the government's job to
step in and fix it or their folks the
government the government causes that it
is particularly and look so we can
debate whether certain movements in
Europe or far right or they're just kind
of populist conservatives or are they
actually far-right I think it's the
wrong question the question is are they
being fueled by legitimate grievances
and I guess I would argue and I say I
argue this someone who ran the largest
per capita immigration program in the
world I would argue that when you are
letting hundreds of thousands of people
illegally or irregularly overrun your
borders that is a legitimate grievance
and if you get any kind of a movement
out of that including a far-right one
don't point the finger at the people for
voting for point the finger at the
policymakers who allowed such a crazy
policy to bring that about that outcome
and fix the policy you know the one
thing I would say that when people you
know it's it's easy to condemn in fact I
had a rule and my you know I United the
conservative movement in Canada been
divided into historically two parties
and various factions but I always said
you know if I got one or two percent on
the right of me that's fine but when you
get 5% or 10% or 20% or infamously with
Hillary Clinton 45 46 % and you're
calling them fringe there's something
wrong with you we live in a Democratic
Society you can't start condemning large
segments of the population as fringe if
they're voting for that you've got to
address their concerns and especially as
I say if their concerns are legitimate
so you can complain about the policies
of those quote far-right parties but
offer an alternative
don't pretend they don't have a
legitimate issue when do you when do you
see a situation in which we may have to
tell people that their concerns are not
legitimate so it seems like that the the
word legitimate gives us a little bit of
wiggle room meaning that it seems to me
that most concerns that you're talking
about are fully legitimate I think folks
who are worried about info
of immigration from countries that don't
share our values who are worried about
an undercutting of our of our labor base
for example like these are legitimate
concerns but I feel like there are
certain concerns that are fundamentally
illegitimate so for example people who
believe that it's the government's job
to protect their their job and in a
dying industry it's an industry that's
being out competed or technologies
replace the job or they're in a dying
town and the populist movement whether
it's right or left basically lies to
these folks and says government is going
to step in and it's going to save your
job it's going to make everything all
better now when when is it appropriate
do you think so so look III go back I I
don't think in a democratic society in
fairness regardless of what our
particular philosophical leanings are
you can actually say to large numbers of
people your concerns are not legitimate
what you can say to them is you don't
think that the solutions that you're
proposing are realistic and here are
realistic solutions that could actually
address your problem greater education
labor mobility etc but I think I think
you're on your you know it's just
fundamental if concept of a Democratic
Society is that the people's views are
fundamentally legitimate and that is the
job of rulers to address them see this
is why I'm so glad I'm a commentator
because I frequently tell people their
concerns are completely illegitimate so
I have an easy job I get to say here is
this this is where this started I would
say you asked me about my political yeah
there's was this got beaten out of me
because you know I became as I said my
early 20s I became a conservative got
disappointed by seeing a centrist
conservative government kind of pursue
ineffective watered-down policies and
then I helped found a new party well the
new party was fundamentally populist
because we had no support from the
corporate sector or very little we were
fundamentally built on ordinary working
middle-class people and the only way you
could raise money was by getting them to
give a little small amounts of money
getting them to donate their time so you
very quickly realized that as in any
other form of activity you're
essentially in a marketplace and a
business and if you don't address the
concerns of your market it's you who is
not legitimate not them I mean that that
may be true you know in terms of
marketing but in terms of morality I
mean when I when I raise my kids there
sometimes where my kids have a a
completely illegitimate grievance in
fact it haven't on a fairly regular
basis their their grievances that you
know they want candy and they can't have
or they don't want to rush their teeth
as my daughter did not last night and
she needs to brush her teeth or she's
going to get cavities
yeah there's certain when is it possible
so he's always like you like you I'm a
man of faith so you know as a man of
faith you believe there's certain God is
constantly there are certain things that
are morally right and certain things
that are morally wrong but I guess what
I'd argue as a more pragmatic politician
is that most things that are morally
wrong are actually pragmatically bad for
you over time and that's why we as
conservatives don't advocate them we
advocate instead solutions that may not
always be what people want to hear but
they've got to be things that at least
address their concerns when somebody
says let me give practical example from
the last campaign a why Donald Trump one
when somebody says you know we've had
the industrialization of my entire
region my kids have no economic
opportunities no jobs etc and your
response to them is well I'll cut the
high marginal rate on taxes it doesn't
really address anything they're worried
about so you've got to come up with
policies that address their concerns and
that's that's where I talk about the
pragmatism right and and and this is
where I get worried and Kanyon can you
know what I promise I'll move your
factory back no because I know I can't
do that but could I make sure you don't
face competition that would cause your
factory to leave when it doesn't have to
you know the problem with some of the
you know traditional center right some
of the traditional conservative friends
arguments is they'll come in they say
well this loss of this was obvious or
inevitable because of automation except
that I know my factory is actually in
Mexico right now so it actually didn't
get automated that's a practical problem
but how many problems do you believe are
brought about by individual decision
making so in a free country it seems to
me that you know for example there's a
Brookings Institute study it basically
says that if you do not want to be in
permanent poverty in the United States
you need to do three things you need to
finish high school you need to get
married before you have babies and you
need to get a job any job anywhere
basically and hold it down and you won't
be in permanent poverty in the United
States and a lot of the folks who are
having problems have made one of these
three mistakes at the very least and we
are now seeing folks who seem to be
using the excuse that it's not not even
consciously they're using the excuse
that this is a very rich country and so
they are owed something and so I'm not
going to
there there I'm not gonna go to North
Dakota where there's a fracking job I'm
gonna stay in my dying town in Ohio and
and be angry that my factory went to
Mexico yeah it was been there's no doubt
that in there is no doubt that that you
know in our democratic societies there's
often and then this does concern me
often a rhetoric that kind of seems to
absolve everybody of responsibility not
just the you know anyone from a worker
who's lost his job at all the way to a
kind of a mass murderer it somehow
wasn't their fault
and and look I have problem with that
but it's not as if policies don't make a
difference and don't really affect
people's lives and let me give once go
once again go back to the example of
trade with China you know people will
say well this was inevitable well first
of all it was not inevitable that our
market would be widely open to Chinese
competition that was a policy decision
but even more importantly it was
certainly not inevitable that we would
open it in a way that did not pry to
provide our workers with the opportunity
of selling products they would make into
China but that's what happened and
that's a legitimate complaint and that
has resulted in the loss of millions of
jobs that kind of decision
now does that absolve the individual
from not being educated or not trying to
find opportunities and enough him or
herself but look we shouldn't you know
we shouldn't I at the same time when
you're an elected person you can't
belittle people I mean people have real
challenges and real problems and not
everybody has the ability to make their
own life from scratch you know we do
depend on family and community and
sometimes from government assistance
that's not all terrible are all
something we should not expect to some
degree so let's talk a little bit about
problems on the Left who spends a lot of
time talking about sort of the
internecine philosophical battles what I
would actually argue on the on the Left
what I actually was say in my book and
if you look around the world the rise of
this populism is actually proving to be
much more problematic on the Left than
on the right because what you had in the
post globalization world is you know
once we kind of develop the basic
underpinnings of a market economy and we
kind of accepted that in principle after
the fall of the Soviet Union you had you
know these new wave liberals come along
the Tony Blair's and the Bill Clinton's
many of whom I know and like and they
kind of propounded a more kind of elite
corporatist market friendly economics
and
and program well what's happening now
with the rise of populist economics
those coalition's are being pulled
asunder and sometimes in ways that are
just you know socialist party in France
Social Democrats in Germany you've got
people you know people are sticking to
that kind of kind of elite liberal
market orient policy people are going
back to traditional socialism and then
those who are attracted by by kind of
right-wing conservative social values
combined with protectionism so you've
got those parties shattering in three
directions so this is actually a much
bigger problem on the left and it's
actually on the right and seems like
it's leading to a tremendous
radicalization of the left I mean the
left is getting more left faster than
the right is getting well what's what's
happening it depends on the country so I
think you see certainly the extreme
example be the Labour Party under Jeremy
Corbyn which is turning into a Marxist
Party which is now purging anyone who's
you know not far left
anyone who's Jewish by the way like
literally you've kind of Stalinist type
purges as it makes itself into an
extreme vehicle in other cases like you
know socialist party in France or Social
Democrats in Germany there being just
reduced to being a kind of a rump party
of kind of center-left liberal elites
with kind of no mass following anymore I
think the Democratic Party looks to me
more headed down the Corbin route but
time will tell so it's different things
are happening in some cases these
parties are being eclipsed by more
radical parties in the law on the left
and in other party cases they're being
taken over do you think this is gonna
lead to you know even more kind of
partisan polarization because this
obviously has led to tremendous kind of
political unrest in the United States to
the point of near violence or in some
cases violence as the left splinters and
we look the right reacts to that the
fundamental point I make in my book is
that these things are being driven the
reason these things are happening we're
seeing a radicalization of the
electorate in virtually every election
in the last three years and the reason
they're happening and it's not a mystery
for a very long period of time the
material lives of large percentages of
the middle and working class have been
getting poorer and when people's lives
get poorer and in particular when their
hopes begin to fade which is what data
really shows about some of these
working-class groups that have
of you know lost their jobs or their
traditional work what happens is that
politics gets angry or politics gets
more difficult I say that you can't
blame that at my point there's no point
blaming that on the policy or on the
individual politicians as a center-right
conservative who's supposed to believe
in traditions and common sense etc you
find common sense solutions that address
those real problems if I could just
maybe back up one point been on kind of
absolving people of responsibility when
I think it's unfair to just say well
it's kind of your fault let's remember
something that happened in the United
States and most other Western
democracies in 2008-2009 not Canada when
the elite and the wealthy got in trouble
the government came in to bail them out
and they all wanted to bail expected a
bailout so it's kind of hard to turn
around and say to the ordinary auto
worker or the ordinary guy working in
the Midwest who's just lost his factory
job somehow it's all your responsibility
to fix your life but by the way if it's
General Motors or if it's you know a
major bank somehow that's the
government's responsibility so I think
we're kind of past that point where it's
kind of hard to make that argument now
that it's the government doesn't bear
some responsibility to ordinary people
for their problems when the government
is prepared to bail out the most wealthy
and powerful members of society so I
actually agree with that but I think the
problem is that that it's possible to
double down in the wrong direction
meaning that I opposed the bailouts
specifically because of this it creates
moral hazard people think that they can
depend on the government and it seems
like okay so we did the wrong thing in
2007-2008 maybe is the necessary thing
but it was still the morally wrong thing
and extending that mentality to folks
leads to this kind of overarching
utopian belief that the government is
always there how'd you say but but it's
it's you know this is where this is
where I'm not a libertarian it's not
because I don't believe in the efficacy
of free markets or I don't believe in
the idea of individual rights it's
because libertarianism runs counter to
data and the fact of the matter is these
things happened and you can't just wish
them not to have happened and pretend
that they have no influence on how
people see the world or their
expectations about the world and you
know the bailouts look I was right there
when this all happened I was running a
g7 country when we did all this I bailed
out the auto sector now why did i bail
at the auto sector
on my 50th birthday you know I wrote a
multi-billion dollar check to the
biggest what what had been some of the
richest companies in Canada some of my
caucus and cabinet resisted its again
why did I do it I did it because I had
to do it I had to do it because the
United States had decided that this
integrated industry would be bailed out
and if Canada did not participate in
that bailout a half a million jobs would
have been moved across the border in
less than a year to the United States I
could not risk that that was not a
realistic choice for me so the choice
was if the United States which owned 83
percent of the industry was going to
bail out the industry governor Canada
would have to bail at its portion that's
just the reality doesn't that incentive
structure exist in virtually every
industry though I mean everybody is
subsidizing someone so where do you
decide to draw the line as far as okay
these jobs deserve to be saved these
jobs don't deserve to be saved this
industry deserves to all doubt this one
so generally generally speaking I you
know I didn't do a lot of billets and I
don't like bailouts generally speaking
you want the market to kind of work out
who's gonna who's gonna grow and who's
gonna fail the problem in that case was
that I said I face the reality that due
to actions of another government beyond
my control I was going to lose hundreds
of thousands of jobs in Canada if I did
not act that way and you can say well
then the real problems of the US us
should not have bailed out the industry
us should have let chapter 11 bankruptcy
take over except that that was a
theoretical possibility when the entire
financial system was not functioning so
you can say if the financial system were
functioning properly I think you could
have made an argument in the United
States yes you could made an argument
let the marketplace sort this out and
probably would have but in late 2008
early 2009 there was no possibility of
that happening so as they say as a
conservative you deal with the world as
it is does some of this offend my idea
of what is ideal economic policy
absolutely but you have to play the
cards you're given and you just can't
wish them away well it seems like you
know obviously in exigent circumstances
you're gonna have to do what you're
gonna have to do but in non exigent
circumstance so right now we're not
experiencing exciting circumstances
right now we now we have a very solidly
growing economy particularly in the
United States we have wage growth for
the first time in a long time
it seems like now
a good time to sort of fundamentally
restructure people's understanding of
what it is the government is supposed to
do for them and fundamentally
restructure in a legal way
what bailouts are available to to come I
say it's just tough when people knew
that things were really bad and you
bailout the wealthy to tell them now the
rest of the time I know the problem is
that at some point the ration only works
in on direction right I mean so look as
I say you you you know you expect you
know we obviously can't have a society
where nobody's responsible for any
aspect of their lives that society will
fail it will inevitably fail no matter
how wealthy we are and that worries me
on the other hand I don't think it's
realistic given the nature of a modern
economy how complex it is what that does
to the underlying social and family
dynamics to expect that government will
not be involved in anything won't help
you with your education it won't help
you with mobility will help you with
anything else it won't provide you tax
incentives anything to help you in your
life I just think that's not a realistic
option either so it sort of feels you
know like it's it's difficult to draw
lines I mean it's sort of like it sounds
like a course or a Potter Stewart take
on pornography when I see it yes so how
much is - how much is too much
government I would say that's that's
about what being a conservative is the
reality is a conservative is that you
recognize that reality is really
complicated I mean one of the reasons we
like a market we like markets these
markets can deal with a lot of
complicated complex micro decisions in
ways that government ET can't but the
reality is that reality is extremely
complicated and we have broad as
conservatives I think we share some
broad social and economic values but the
fact of the matter is we'll find
different cases where different policies
are appropriate and that's not just base
the important thing is that's not based
on political expediency that's based on
dealing with the reality of the economic
and political situation and social
situation in front of you I mean to a
certain extent aren't those the same
thing no I mean political expediency
being you know dealing with the
situation in front of you and the best
possible way meaning that well they can
be but they don't have to be you know
look if I theoretically I guess in 2009
ICO 2008-2009 I could have said I'm not
bailing out the auto industry it only
operates in one part of the country the
rest of the country will cheer the
problem is that I knew forget about the
loss of political votes
some people and the gain from others the
problem is I knew that the outcome of
that decision would be very bad for the
economy as a whole
and would I think probably everybody
would eventually have hated me making
that decision so you can call that
political expediency but that's actually
reality I mean this is one of the
reasons why we are Democrats right one
of the reasons we are Democrats is that
how people think and feel and react
actually matters as opposed to just our
blueprint view of the world Hey and this
is one of the reasons why I'm very much
on board with the founding fathers
vision of democracy it's as you know got
a I got a check it so they didn't just
mob rule because obviously there's a
line to be drawn between the passions of
the public and what is legitimate policy
and invasion of rights yeah let's talk
for a second about foreign policy
because some of the most controversial
decisions you made when you're a prime
minister had to do with foreign policy
and we are seeing when we talk about
splits in foreign policy in in terms of
left and right no are we seeing this
more broadly than then on foreign policy
rights right now why do you think it is
that the left has moved so far in one
direction on foreign policy I don't just
mean with regard to sort of open borders
immigration but with regard to the Iran
deal with regard to with regard to
Middle Eastern policy it seems like
you're you're obviously as a as a Jew I
was very familiar with your record on
Israel as Prime Minister of Canada very
grateful for it as well why do you think
it is that the left has moved so far in
the anti-israel direction so that's a
good question and one of the there were
many things that caused me to gravitate
from being a kind of a liberal guy when
I was really young too conservative as
an adult and it wasn't all the
experiences of a national energy program
you know my father would have been
considered a liberal in his era you know
he was a he was a vocal opponent of
anti-semitism when Andy Summers was
extremely common in Canada you know he
was a vocal supporter of civil wrote we
would now call civil rights the you know
movements of blacks and others to have
to have voting and other rights he would
be very vocal is this a young man but I
think by the time I became kind of him
by the 1980s I started to detect that
modern the modern liberalism or modern
left side of the spectrum even in the
center was going in a different
action it was no longer about you know
actually empowering people who had been
downtrodden it started becoming more
fundamentally kind of a hatred of our
own society what I call alien ism the
opposite of nationalism our culture is
wrong our values are wrong the other
guy's always right and so I support
Israel to take the Israel situation I
support Israel as tell people my views
are not religious in nature and it's not
a biblical interpretation I support
Israel because I see Israel's part of
the Western Democratic Society of
Nations a vital ally in the most
dangerous part of the world
and I see a retreat are retreating or
abandoning Israel in that position of
the world as detrimental a long-term to
our own basic national self-interest I
think it is critical the Western
countries support Israel I think it is
incredibly myopic and dangerous
politicians who for various other
political expediency reasons why to
abandon Israel but I think the reason
you see so much antipathy to Israel on
the left is for precisely the same
reason they see in Israel a society like
ours and they want to blame it for all
the problems of the region which is
nonsense and you know there's this deep
dislike of our society of the united
states of the west and they see Israel
as a manifestation of that so that's the
part and I just and I could say every
liberal things like this but I see this
you know we and we can point to extreme
examples of this extreme examples but
examples that are common you know a
perfect example is I saw it recently on
one of your TV shows a liberal talk
radio host talking about you know
supporting the right of Muslim women to
cover their face because no man should
tell a woman how to dress well what do
you think that is that is a man calling
a walk telling a woman how to dress but
you know you you choose in your liberal
mindset to see that as the but as the
valid manifestation of some other
culture just because it's another
culture and somehow it then becomes a
good thing that you see is you see as
Western feminism instead of as as is as
Islamic is kind of extreme form of of
the of the anti women aspect of of
Islamism but you see this all the time
and
this is the part of the modern left and
you see it all through foreign policy we
are always to blame we are always at
fault and we have nothing but to kind of
beg forgiveness and learn from other
societies and I have a very different
view and I'm not going to say Western
society or Canadian Society is has been
or is faultless but these are the most
successful freest prosperous societies
in the world and they've also been the
most dynamic resilient and adaptable
societies also the ones most likely to
admit incorrect error and the idea that
we should somehow be ashamed of our
societies or that we should kind of kind
of go out into the world with perpetual
self-doubt and and flagellation I just
think is an aspect of modern liberalism
I can't accept I mean I think it's a
very fundamental to all of the foreign
policy I mean I obviously agree and
what's in it was kind of fascinating
those you actually do see the strain in
some elements of American libertarianism
and even in populism this sort of
isolationist withdrawal from the world
mentality what do you make of that and
why do you think that there's this sort
of horseshoe effect that you go far
enough in one direction you end up back
at this isolation yeah I see less
isolationism and kind of what's happened
with Trump and kind of American populism
than some I think it's more accurately
described as unilateralism than
isolationism is very different and and I
I don't think it's not without concerns
I don't on the other hand don't think
it's always the case the multilateral
institutions have been working really
well for the United States or even for
the West as a whole so I I do think a
new balance needs to be struck but you
know look it's still important United
States may tell people I a very
pro-american as you know the United
States is the most powerful and
important country in the world and
certainly to Canada it is the most
important and powerful country in the
world but that doesn't mean the United
States can go into the world with no
allies and no friends and expect to
prosper in the long term I do think
unilateralism in the extreme is as bad
as multilateralism in the extreme well
Prime Minister Harper I do have one more
question for you I want you to grade
President Trump but if you want to hear
Prime Minister Harper's answer you have
to go over to Daley wired.com slash
subscribe to get the rest of our
wonderful subscriber benefits if you get
the annual subscription yet one of these
leftt is
here's Heydrich old tumblers you got all
those things when you go to daily wear
comm / subscribe subscribe now to hear
Prime Minister Harper's answer well it
was such a pleasure to have Prime
Minister Harper here his new book is
right here right now politics and
leadership in the age of disruption
Prime Minister thank you so much for
stopping thanks for having me appreciate
[Music]
eventually rose shows Sunday special is
produced by Jonathan hey executive
producer Jeremy Boren associate producer
Mathis Glover edited by Alex in Durham
audio is mixed by Dylan case hair and
makeup is by Jess wah
Oliveira and title graphics by Cynthia
and hula the Ben Shapiro shows Sunday
special is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright Ford
publishing 2018
[Music]